[Music]
let's go to austin texas where michelle
joins us michelle how can we help
hi um thank you for taking my call so
i had a question just regarding my
roommate situation
uh the past year has been a real roller
coaster
and um
the lease is coming up to an end on
sunday
my uh roommate isn't
communicating with me and hasn't paid
her september rent still and it's the
22nd now so i'm just and she's blocked
me
so i'm just wondering how to kind of go
about this situation
um and like i don't know if i should
confront her in person or yes what
really to do
i'm gonna jump ahead in front of john on
that one yes literally my question was
is she still sleeping in the same place
brick your door like how do you block
somebody in real life y'all live in the
same room and you answered it for me
should you talk to in person
god almighty please help all of us yes
yes
um so i've actually moved out um and i
think she's moving the rest of her stuff
out today but i know you're guessing
just go over and have a human
interaction a polite respectful
dignified one and if she acts like a
maniac or a jerk you can say hey
you don't have permission to talk to me
that way um here is a letter that says
here's your notice that you're going to
be moving out and then you have peace in
your heart and you go around about your
day but you have so much chaos in your
heart because you don't have real
information because you haven't had a
real human conversation with another
real human what happened yeah
um like what happened what happened with
you too to where you feel like you can't
just go hey look we don't have to like
each other uh we're certainly not going
to live together anymore but can you be
a big girl put your big girl pants on
and pay your part of the rent like what
happened to where you're so terrified of
that
um
she's just a very mean and ugly person
i've confronted her
about things um in person before and it
got really ugly so like that's kind of
why i'm i'm scared yeah so let me let me
tell you this are you are you unsafe
um just
like just her words are super super
hurtful okay
so there's a there is a middle ground
between no communication
and the words you used you you've used
it a couple of times which is to
confront
the gap in between is just a
conversation
that can start instead of hey you
haven't paid rent what's been going on
why'd you block me
hey are you okay
how how are you
i haven't talked to you in a long time
and i want to
i miss talking to you are you okay
i care about you yeah
in one of those conversations your body
responds it dumps adrenaline cortisol
into your bloodstream you start uptaking
glucose because your body's ready to
fight somebody
and there's a you don't have to get
there
if you're not safe
if you think you're going to get hurt
physically don't show up there
when you took on a business arrangement
with somebody you took on that
discomfort you need to have that
conversation
and if she says mean things you can turn
around and walk away in person and say
you're not going to talk to me that way
thank you very much yeah and then be on
about your day yeah and here's the deal
john's absolutely right and if you do
all the things he tells you and she
still comes at you hot
you can't fix that no she's trying to
make this difficult for her own reasons
and maybe some of she doesn't even know
why she's doing it that's john's area
but i'll say this
i would stay very calm and say look
there are repercussions to this i'm
going to pay my part you got to pay your
part i'm not going to bother you ever
again i'm not trying to get in your
business i hope you're okay i hope
you're okay i i'm so sorry for anything
that i've done just go real blanket here
really easy and just go hey
we just you need to do this thing so i'm
just trying to facilitate you let's get
a clean fresh start and if you've
already moved out yeah then walk away if
you've moved out and you signed this
lease and subleased it yeah then you owe
that money yeah you can
sue her for it you can go through all
the drama or you can learn a hard lesson
yeah and then you can move on about your
day yeah and again you hear me again our
voices check
you can get amped up nobody makes good
decisions when they're amped up calm is
contagious
coming in low as you possibly can and
say here's the reality of our situation
and let's move on with their day yeah
yeah and and
john let me ask you this because from a
professional standpoint
when she does that she takes the power
away from this gal this gal's definitely
made a power play the nastiness and all
that whether she's hurting or not it's a
power play yeah and it's working i mean
michelle's really really hurt that's
right she's shaken up i'm not gonna give
i'm not gonna give somebody that level
of power over my life i agree i'm not
gonna let the guy driving next to me who
i is just cut me off i'm not gonna give
him access to my blood pressure i'm not
i'm not gonna give him access to
being angry and yelling at my kids when
i get home because i'm all amped up and
fired up because someone didn't drive
the way i wanted them to i'm not going
to give them that access to me if they
put me in a position where they want to
fight me i'm going to walk away because
i'm a grown-up you know i mean like i'm
not going to engage in that that's just
a waste of my time and energy yeah and
so i get to control what i'm bringing to
the situation and the only other option
outside of that is i need to get
something out of that house and i'm
going to be i am in danger being
physically harmed that's right then i'm
going to bring the police with that's
right yeah other than that i'm just not
going to give people access to me yeah
and that's what and so it that's easier
said than done but we've got absolutely
we've got to detach ourselves in this
situation michelle's got to detach
herself from all the mean and hurtful
things and realize she's playing me yeah
i don't have to know everything i don't
have to be a a psychiatrist and figure
it out what i do know is she's playing
me she's been nasty i can't fix that i
need a rent or else i'm on the line
a lot of folks
get engaged with somebody who's nasty
whether it's a boss whether it's a
spouse whether it's a
um roommate
and we spend a lot of energy
wondering why what it is about us that
is invoking the nasty
what is it about me that is making you
treat me this way
and that's a wrong way to approach a
relationship issue
that's me thinking i'm deficient and i'm
trying to get you to solve it and the uh
the way to flip that on its head is to
say i'm a person of dignity you're going
to treat me with respect and you're not
going to talk to me in this way
and if you are yelling at me that means
you've got an issue not me because see
that's great does that make sense
it's not my problem to solve for you it
makes total sense but i think that most
of us screw that up
yeah if you have a boss that's treating
you like a jerk you kind of go what did
i do
now if your boss calls you in and says
the work you turned in is garbage it's
not good you need to up then that's your
problem to solve but if they yell at you
they belittle you they act like that's
their problem and the decision from this
point over is your choice to make right
that's good boy that's really good and
that's how you kind of take that attack
it's not giving you that let it sting so
much and since this is the ramsay show
you know an awesome way to detach
yourself is not owe anybody anything and
have a fully funded emergency fund yeah
and don't rely on a roommate if you
don't have to i'm going to walk away
that keeps it pretty great
yeah yeah good stuff